So we have the settings icon where we have to set up, in settings you will have the option
of academics.
By clicking on academics, you will have various options defined in which you have to work.
Sir, is this much clear at the end of all of you?
Yes, it is clear.
Now what we have to do is create a timetable, so the first step for timetable is to define
the subjects in the system, after defining the subjects, you have to define the subject
class mapping.
So first of all, we have to define the subjects in the system, you have the first option,
now I don't have any subject in the system, you have the option at the top, add subject.
You will click on this, I am creating a subject, English, subject name, then there is a unique
code of the subject, it may be that the name of the subject is common, but there is a code
that defines it.
I have put the code, three digit code ENG, then it has an assessment model, scholastic
subject, course scholastic subject.
Scholastic subjects are basically those subjects in which we have to do marks entry.
For example, like your GK, your primary classes, GK, which are your small classes, in that
case your course is scholastic or in the discipline, basically you use grading criteria for it,
teachers enter the grade, so we have created four assessment models.
Can I interrupt a little?
Yes, yes, tell me.
The subject name is English, it will be of everyone, English is in 7th, will this subject
code be different for 6th and 7th?
No, no, no, no, no, it remains the same, this subject code is defining your subject,
it will not define your class, it is only defining your subject, as can be general knowledge,
you have to use general knowledge, you have to use GK, so that is done for that.
I have made the assessment model scholastic.
Sir, we have the option to define class and stream, there are some such subjects, we want
that when we create mapping, it should only show in these particular classes, not in all
So in that case, you can map a particular class here, for example, there is a subject
that I want, only when I make a mapping of 5th and 6th class, it should only display me,
it should not display in other classes, it should not be able to add, so in that case
I can select this in a particular class, for example, my English is for everyone, so I
did not select a particular class, I will just add a simple one, this is my subject
added.
In this way, you can add subjects according to your classes, or you can add a simple
subject in the system, you can add the data of the subjects.
Excuse me ma'am.
Yes ma'am.
Ma'am, can we give the code, is it necessary to give?
Ma'am, this is necessary to give, you can add someone else according to your classes,
for example, I used ENG for English.
In this way, code is considered a mandatory field in our system, code is mandatory.
You can add anything according to your classes, you can use HIN for Hindi, you can use MAT
for Math, kind of.
This was the subject, sir, let's move ahead, is there any query for any subject?
No ma'am, it's okay.
Okay sir, one more thing I want to clear here, the subjects we have created, it is possible
that later you have to change something in the name of the subject, you feel that I have
to change its name, right?
So in that case, if you have only created this subject so far, I have not added it in
any class in mapping, so I can edit it till then, whatever I want to edit in it, but if
I have added it in mapping, then I cannot edit it from here, then I can only change
its display name, I cannot change the name of the subject.
Okay sir, then now we have created the subjects, then we have the created subjects,
we have to map them in their respective class, right?
That is an option in the subject class mapping.
Okay, subject course mapping and subject class mapping, you can call it that.
In this, you have the first option, add new subject class mapping, right?
You will click on this, then you will define the class, you are making it for the fifth
class, there is one option left, we can select multi, you feel that in fifth, sixth, seventh
I have common subjects, first you can create three classes together, okay?
Class fifth, by default it will select the stream and by default it will select all
the sections, okay?
I will create a single section now.
Then after that, you have to add the detail of the subject, means in class fifth, you have
to add all the subjects, you are defining the subjects.
Okay, I have added the subject, I have the subject, the subjects that I have created
there, its list comes to me here.
I will type and select according to the drop down.
Now the assessment model that I have added there, my assessment model has come.
Then you have the subject type, what is the subject type basically?
There are some such subjects for some classes, which are optional subjects,
which are also optional, which are not general, which are not common for all students.
Okay?
So now there is English, English is common for all the students.
So all the students in this class, I have to apply this subject from here.
There is no such option that two children have it, three children do not have it.
So now we will do general.
But in case like we have in class fifth, sixth, GK came, drawing came, Punjabi,
so all these subjects are optional.
Okay, so in that case you can use this option.
If you make an option from here, then what will happen from here,
you define in subject mapping that it is an optional subject,
it will not be applied to all students.
And then you will go ahead and define it in the next step.
Okay, for now, I will just do this as a general and add it from here.
Okay, this is my mapping created, in which one subject has been added.
Okay, the rest you had the option from here only.
You add more subjects in this, that is, other than this,
you will keep adding subjects from here.
Okay, next subject, in this way, your whole list will be created,
how many subjects are coming in this class.
Okay, sir, is there any other query in this part?
I will explain it to you.
Okay, then what happens with us now,
we have created the class, defined the subjects in it.
Now basically, who is the class teacher in this class,
who is its coordinator, who is the subject's corresponding subject teacher,
so we have to define that.
Okay, class 5th, class 5th in class A,
who is my class teacher, you have a list of employees.
Right, the ID of the employees we have created.
You will define from here, for example, this is my class teacher,
so I have set it here as a class teacher.
You can also assign a coordinator to any other employee.
Okay, in class teacher, we have an option,
that we can map a single employee,
because the class teacher is always single for a class.
But if you want to do multiple,
then you can use the coordinator,
you can map all the coordinators for this class.
Okay, and one more thing,
those who are mapped by the class teacher and coordinator,
they have all the subjects of a particular class,
so they have access to all those subjects.
Now you feel that you have to give a single class,
sorry, you have to give a single subject,
for example, if it is a subject teacher,
then from here, the subject teacher is mapped.
In the same subject teacher, you also have an option,
you can set multiple subject teachers.
Okay, this was our teacher mapping.
Now there is one more thing, as I told you,
by chance you feel that the name of the subject,
I have to define something else.
So in that case, this is the display name,
now the display name that you give,
as you will accentuate the visible at the end of the student,
then that display name will appear,
which you will give the display name here.
Okay sir, if I will edit this normal from here,
I have done this single subject,
now I will edit it, so I have this teacher map in it.
Okay, it is showing you that the subject of English,
what is the inflow added in it.
This is what I have created right now,
I have not assigned it to anyone,
because this is what I have done to show you,
I have put the display name ENG,
so now I have ENG name everywhere.
Okay sir, we have this edit,
after every mapping is created,
whatever changes you want to make further,
you can make changes from here.
Then we have the option to assign by default,
all the general subjects added,
you will select them from here,
if you assign them, then they will be assigned to all the students in the class.
I am not doing it right now,
because we are making it according to the test,
so I am not assigning the students.
Okay sir, let's move forward with this part.
Okay sir, tell me one thing, do you have the criteria of optional subjects?
Do you have the criteria of optional subjects?
Yes sir, absolutely.
Okay sir, I will explain it once.
For example, the subject I have is an optional subject,
or it can be additional or vocational,
you have to set it according to that,
then you have to edit it.
After that, you have defined it as optional,
but from here you can put it in bulk,
then you can assign it to all the students.
If it is an optional subject, then it will not be assigned to all,
but it will be assigned to some students.
For that, you have a separate option for the assigned subject.
We assign the optional subjects from here,
you have selected the class,
you have a list of the students of that class.
Now, which of these students
do you want to assign the English optional subject to?
So, you will select from here,
the students you have selected,
after selecting, you have the option of assigned subject.
You have created that option there,
and here you will get that subject.
As soon as you add this subject,
it will only be assigned to those students
whom you have selected, not to all.
It will be assigned to all the students
from here.
Let me tell you again,
you have mapped it as a general,
you have to map it as a general instead of optional.
As soon as you have mapped it as a general,
you can also assign it directly from here.
I am not doing it now, it will be assigned to all the students.
Normally, you will assign it to all the students.
Otherwise, you have the option from outside,
you have the same icon from here,
if you select and assign it, it will be assigned to all the students.
Then, this was the part of creating the subject,
of creating the subject class mapping.
Now, according to this, we will define our timetable.
For that, you will have the option of timetable.
You will do that part,
and from here, we will define the timetable,
that in one class, this is the subject, this is the teacher,
how you have mapped it in the future.
For example, I will create a timetable,
add new timetable.
You have selected the class, I have a single class in mapping.
So, you are making a timetable of a single class.
After that, add a new schedule.
Now, you will define it, you will get the lecture number.
Lecture number 1, when is your lecture number 1 starting?
Start time, end time, or just a minute.
Yes, sir.
Shall we continue, sir?
One minute.
What we have to do is add a schedule.
In the schedule, first we have lecture number 1.
In the fifth class, when is the lecture number 1 starting?
For example, my exact start time is 8 am.
From 8 am to 8.45 am is my first lecture.
From 8.45 am to 8.45 am is my first lecture.
After that, you can save this schedule.
Or you can add more lectures after this.
You have defined the second lecture.
First lecture is my 8.2, 8.40.
Then automatically, lecture 2 starts from 8.40.
From 8.40 am to 8.40 am is my second lecture.
Can you tell me sir, when is your second lecture?
From 9.20 am to 9.20 am.
Now I am creating only two lectures.
I have created two lectures, saved the schedule.
I am asking for all the schedules.
Sir, you have to add all the timings.
From 9.20 am to 9.20 am is my third lecture.
From 10.00 am to 10.00 am is my third lecture.
Then your fourth lecture will come.
How long is your fourth lecture?
From 10.40 am to 10.40 am.
When is your break after this?
After 10.40 am, I have a break of 10 minutes.
So this is your break in lecture 5.
Yes, I have a break of 10.50 am.
Then your lecture is 6.
This is from 10.50 am to 11.30 am.
From 11.30 am to 11.30 am.
Then you can do it from 11.30 am.
Then it will be a break of 35 minutes.
Then you can do it from 11.30 am to 12.40 am.
Then you can do it from 12.40 am.
Then you can do it from 11.30 am.
Yes, after 6.00 am there will be a break.
Was it after 6.00 am?
No, they will do it from there.
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
how is the subject?
You have to add the name of the subject.
Right now there is a single subject.
You will add the subject.
Employee, I have selected two teachers
for English for the subject.
I will push and I will get the subject.
I will remove it.
You can also remove it from here.
I clicked on it.
Subject, English, employee's name.
Push and the teacher will map it.
If you feel there is someone else on Tuesday,
then the same option will be there.
If you feel you have to define the break,
then define the break from here.
Then define the break from here.
You can also run two subjects at the same time.
There is also an option for another.
If there is someone else here,
then you can add that too.
On Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
it is proper.
Simply define the subject.
Define the subject and push from there.
On that date,
there is a break in that time period.
If you click on that and turn on the toggle
of this break, then it will be your break.
Same push and remove.
Both options are there.
In this much part,
how to create a timetable in a query?
Bye.